Mất nẩn thương nhiên, lột nhập tiếp vàng trong đêm, quốc đi nh Elec, phàn lộng hồ.
Θy nào, ngày 27,5 năm, không xam hai bế tư.
Con hoàn hửi lộc tiếp nhận lên chình báo, của trụ một tiếp vàng trên đệ bàn xã Người Sôn.
Để việc Mỹ kể giặt lần nhập Chọn Tháp Tài Sản chỉ la cận 3 chjäng chuẩn đồng.
Ngay sơ kêu nhìn được tiếp báo, Con hoàn hửi lộc đã ngành trong kế này sách miền, khả miệng sự giữ giữ bệnh tháp
khi phục đề điều tra, chỉ hơn 2 ngày sau khi tiếp nhận tình chính báo, bán trên án đã sách định được lửa tự nghi vẫn thực hiện thành vi chục các tài sản tại tệ văn sáng gây sân.
Lâm đến thành vi, xin năm nay nạn công trong lịch tư, chú tạc khối một, có gióa, tí sách hợi lò.
Nếu một mô tháng mề mô, nó tháng ngàn công trong hai mịch tư, sau khi tụ tập này đủ tay liệu, chứng cưỡ, bán trên án đã bất sức lửa tự nghiến thành vi,
trong các tài sản, măn trên án thu dứng tăng vật mà gồm bà bị bệ dễ chuyển văn.
Bởi lấp văn, hai nhìn bà, mô xây bà và bà đồng hồ, tập chỉ sả cân bà chăm chụi lòng.
Số tăng vật này được lửa tự cất sấu tại các khu bực vóng xanh cư, thu phân nghĩ hơn, tí sát cự lò.
Hết công an về y lọc đăng tạm dưới lửa tự nghiến thành vi, đông tơi hoang két hô sơ để khởi tố phụ an theo quy định pháp lật.